it's the difference between  people who voted for trump and who  ride around with the flags and the hats  sex right there's [ __ ]  they're i call them cult members but you  know what though  a lot of people got a lot of people who  didn't vote for biden  because of the tax increase  that's what i'm saying dumb [ __ ] this  is the camera right here  yeah you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] the tax  increase was for people that was making  400  000 or more or more [ __ ] you ain't  making that much money getting broke  and you were talking about are you  worried about a [ __ ] tax increase  never you just ordered off the dollar  menu at taco bell  not even that like yo [ __ ] aight  he's gonna be president for like four  years probably not  another president come around and you  know we'll know how that's right